OverWatch 2's problems continue and Call
of Duty wants your number
OverWatch 2's launch continues to be a
bumpy one and this time blizzard has
taken Bastion and torbjorn offline in
order to fix bugs in their kits Bastion
will be completely unavailable in any
mode but players can still select
torbjorn in quick play blizzard didn't
stay exactly which bugs it's fixing but
reports of Bastion being able to
infinitely shoot during its alt upon
certain conditions have been going
around torbjorn's bug appears to be a
lengthened duration of his overload
Ability Beyond these two Heroes who are
intentionally temporarily gone players
have also reported that they can access
other Heroes on their roster blizzard
has confirmed this bug and said it is
looking into the issue OverWatch 2 went
down for emergency maintenance late in
the evening on October 10th but right
after the maintenance ended blizzard
reported another DDOS attack the company
just can't catch a break during
OverWatch 2's launch in other blizzard
news Call of Duty Modern War Warfare 2
players will be required to provide a
phone number connected to a valid data
plan additionally VoIP and prepaid
numbers won't work this decision is
apparently a part of a company-wide
initiative at Activision Blizzard to
fight toxic behavior in its multiplayer
games we saw the policy in action last
week at OverWatch 2's launch which led
to some controversy in theory this
requirement will prevent abusive players
such as Smurfs and boosters for making
new accounts which means they'll be held
accountable for their actions however
restricting the OIP and prepaid numbers
might stop Hackers from warming their
way back into the system but it also has
the unfortunate side effect of blocking
people who rely on such services from
playing the game entirely additionally
given that prepaid phones are often
cheaper than their competition this
policy definitely hits poor and
underprivileged people the hardest as
well as kids who are too young to have
their own phones while OverWatch 2 isn't
the first game to require a valid phone
number to play online reports from The
Verge and the general player base
suggests that Battle.net is being more
strict about the prepaid and VoIP phone
plans than games like DOTA 2. in
response to the controversy Activision
Blizzard announced that they will waive
the phone policy for those who have
played the original OverWatch and have a
connectedbattle.net account however new
users must still provide a phone number
and in other Call of Duty news the ghost
of Hope a notable Call of Duty leaker
claims that several pro soccer players
will arrive in Modern Warfare 2 and
Warzone 2.0 if this leak is true players
may be able to hop into a match of
multiplayer or Battle Royale as Lionel
Messi or Neymar Jr just two names on the
list of allegedly leaked operator skins
leave a comment down below letting us
know what type of skins you want in
Modern Warfare 2 and we'll see you
tomorrow
foreign